good evening and we begin with breaking
news and the U.S Coast Guard says a
debris field has been discovered by a
remote underwater vehicle searching the
Atlantic for a missing submersible we
understand that the debris includes
parts of the missing vessel earlier
officials predicted that the oxygen
supply on board the Titan ran out at
eight minutes past 12. this afternoon UK
time five men including three britons
are on board the vessel
now in the last hour we've been talking
to David merns a rescue a safety uh
search and rescue expert who also knows
two of the men on board the Titan and he
has been talking to us in the last few
minutes about some information uh David
that you have and that seems to suggest
and it's information from
um out in the Atlantic and is
information that says that these this
debris field is
so what are you hearing it's being
relayed from the ships uh to the
president of the Explorers Club who's
been across this entire thing for the
past several days that that what has
been found in terms of debris is that
the landing frame and also a rear cover
so it means the actual Hull hasn't yet
been found but two very important parts
of the whole system have been discovered
and that would not be
found unless this this it's fragmented
it's you know it's coming apart so this
picture here we're seeing now that that
the landing frame you're talking about
at the bottom yes and it sits on that
it's bolted to that and that's how it uh
docks itself into the launch and
recovery system and then the
back sort of like fishtail
shape that's essentially what we call a
fairing inside of that will be
electronics and all sorts of things and
that's a fairing just to make it smooth
it's a cover that was bolted but it
comes off you know uh relatively easy so
if the fairing
is off and the frame is off well
something very bad has happened to the
entire structure right
so so on the news that we have yet they
haven't found the hull of which the men
are inside
um you know but what does it suggest the
information you're getting now what does
it suggest everything that has happened
you know something catastrophic you know
these things are not
they're not uh they're not connected to
the rest of the frame or the structure
or just by you know
um masking tape they're bolted they're
they're many bolts there'll be
and then an important part of the
structure the whole weight of the hull
which is the heaviest bit is resting on
that frame so the
um the brackets that tie that frame to
the rest of the hull you can see those
rings around it
are key structural elements of this
configuration right and for that frame
to be separated from the hull
is not good and what was the other bit
the fairing the thing that says Ocean
Gate Titan right so that's just the
shape that they probably made because it
looks cool and looks like a fish and
looks
um you know sort of marine-like but it's
it's a fairing it's a cover that comes
off right now this is information not
from the US Coast Guard we are getting
most of our information this is
information you are receiving for for
just explain to me how this information
is coming to you so this is from people
in touch with
Rescuers that's right or recovery
workers at the seat or people who are
getting the information pretty much
firsthand and and I've asked them
so they haven't found the hole yet and
and all they come back is that that's it
so far so
again you know
listen we don't want to be
do merchants here and predicting the
worst when it hasn't happened but you
know we know the terminology that people
use and the Coast Guard wouldn't be
using debris and they wouldn't be
reporting that from the scene unless
this wasn't good and from just looking
at that and understanding how that
structure is built together if those two
components are not are no longer
connected to that Hull then something
very drastically
bad has happened then
and the image we're also seeing is this
is of the
the vessels the Marine Traffic uh in the
area and presumably the search goes on
for other parts of the yes so the vessel
the four
right where it says RMS Titanic those
four blue dots those are the four key
ships
two of them are diving with six thousand
meter rovs that is the Horizon Arctic
and that had the ROV that apparently
found it the Ulysses uh so the arrival
of these rovs today today yes and they
went down this morning this is what has
changed things that's right that's right
and they weren't on scene till today
the previous ships and this is what was
quite frustrating frustrating yesterday
two other ships had rovs on board but
um despite what we were hearing from the
Coast Guard briefing I don't believe
they ever reached the bottom they were
never searching on the bottom and they
were also searching
about two and a half miles to the east
of this location where they were focused
were on these apparent tappings well now
we know that that wasn't real that was
spurious
and today
when the true deep diving or rovs
arrived the 6 000 meter ones on board
the French vessel atalante and also on
the horizon Arctic they all centered on
Titanic and that told me that
they had gone to a new location they had
given up on this position where they
thought they had heard tapping they're
now going to the most likely location
when these Subs die when these Subs dive
these tourist Dives almost anybody who
comes on on Titanic what they want to do
the classic Titanic experience is to
come up on the bow
so you start from outside of the debris
field you dive down and then you
approach the bow and you come up to the
point the end of it and it gives you
that thrill of seeing the bow of Titanic
which is the best looking part of it
it's also the safest way to approach
direct because you're not going through
this field of wreckage you're coming up
to the biggest part of the ship